best batman of all time huh
i figured that'll be the news story
right if you think of actors you don't
really think of education
in general
i mean you look at me you just think oh
he's just the best batman of all time
big day for you congratulations excited
it's exciting do you hear a loud noise
in your my ear because i sound
there we go so yeah we're excited about
this we feel like uh um there's a real
opportunity here and it's something that
i think we've missed in our industry
and i think it's something that it's
pretty obvious what the solution is
and it's starting earlier why was it
important for you to make sure you were
helping spearhead all of this
i
i just felt like you know part of what i
look at is if you see it a hole you try
to fill it and and this is one that it
just seemed like i was in london and we
were staffing up and because it's been a
very busy time in the industry it's hard
to find crew and uh and we need to we
need to do a lot better about
inclusivity could we see you teaching a
course here yeah yeah i'm gonna come in
listen this is below the line guys right
so that you know i'm not really gonna
come in and
talk about directing or acting but uh
but i i can come in and sit down with
the kids when they're editing and stuff
like that so something like that how do
you and them all feel about your
children possibly pursuing a career in
the arts if they would like to they can
do whatever they want you know i would
my guess is that they're they're a
little smarter than me so they'll
probably do something they already speak
three languages so i'm still working on
english
well they have the best teacher in-house
with you if they do pursue the arts now
i wanted to ask you of course we're
going to talk to you soon about ticket
to paradise but the uk premiere was
delayed in the wake of the queen's
passing why was that the right decision
to make well because people are in
mourning and it's not the time to do it
and
it was such an easy decision there was
no hesitation it just feels like look
we'll all get back to our lives as we
will but we have to have a moment to
have
the respect of the of the queen and of
the office
[Music]
you